[Music]
we're wounded
broken
trying desperately to keep ourselves
going by pretending we're
not poor poor uh
doesn't know we should get her food and
water
welcome to the bill
cds will be the capital city of our
belter nation
a place all belters and forever call
home
i just received words they've located in
our assistant
you have something in mind
i do
permission to come aboard
what's going on the old lady leaves the
rossi as the best option for this
operation
are you getting paid actually for this
there's a war on
captain drummer we was golden bow
now we fight with you
good i'm ready for a fight
a war will come soon enough
motherlode
[Music]
he's better with you at his side
[Music]
how do i say philip i failed firing one
[Music]
in the end
the only thing that matters is fighting
for who's covering your fact
i want about to see what it's doing to
i want them us see the lives we've lost
the pain we've suffered
i never loved you because you were
fighters
i loved you because you were builders
you need something
to give us a reason
to hope
[Music]
who's there
[Music]
[Music]
you